[Applause]
oh and one jazz shoots one the other way
and there's the marlins first hit
by bowman third lead off knock here in
the fourth
that'll be interesting to see i know as
fearless as jazz is
this combination has been one that has
stopped well there you go won't need to
steal that one gets away from hoskins
and up to second he goes and now that
one gets away
but backing up is
mccutchen in left field
that's probably on hoskins he just kind
of whiffed
not a perfect throw but under the glove
wheeler's only given up one stolen base
in the last two seasons
he's not even giving up one this year
go back to last year base dealers were
one for one
and the other way miggy
into right field here comes harper's
throw
now hold jazz first and third
well how many times have we seen niggy
row we talk about
situational hitting
rojas everything about that swing going
the other way
jazz flying around the bases
into center field herrera
makes the catch
here comes jazz he will score the game's
first run it's a sac fly for adam duvall
and the marlins take a one-nothing lead
get him on get him over get him in
this pitch up with his zone
herrera in then back out
he positioned himself well for even
jazz at the plate very interesting how
these two innings have played themselves
out right let's not forget wheeler led
off with a double andrew mccutchen
failed to get wheeler to third base
got his signs he's ready to go and the
2-2
swing and a miss he got him threw him a
change change-up ten strikeouts for
wheeler for the tenth time in his career
you read fastball here i think i gotta
catch up to him
he's not very happy with himself way out
in front
[Music]
i guess you geared up for 99. that shows
you his good arm speed on that
and then you know what wallach ends up
doing at home plate
great job by duval
and now bowm
off the wall and right
duval gets it in harper stops
there's another one that's another
outfield assist for adam duvall
how do you like that his fifth
throws an absolute bullet to second base
and gets boom two away well every time
we seem to give duval some praise in the
outfield he kind of one-ups us he does
it he's done it again literally to the
pitch
now he made this look easy a rocket off
the bat of bohme
played perfectly off the wall by duvall
and an even more
perfect throw
my goodness
one and two to sierra
[Applause]
mueller's set to go and he delivers a
little tapper back to the mound
wheeler's got it throws to first hits
1-3 on the put out
can't wait to see how hard that was over
the first base no runs two hits
two men left
time to stretch
[Music]
last year his ground ball rate was 70
percent
[Applause]
and there's another ground ball it's
going to be a tough play
aguilar flips and miller is out at first
i didn't think there was any chance they
were going to get him neither did i
maybe they didn't who knows the phillies
are going to look at it
i think if brad had run through the bag
you think benny would have made it yes i
i
i just don't like the head first into
first
they're gonna look at it then i sonia
was giving him a five count
[Music]
i don't know if flyer ever got the bag
[Music]
hands on the bag to your left ball's not
in the glove yet to your right that we
we sync those up perfectly so the timing
is right so if they look at that you
would deem him being safe right and
again
ben you mentioned the heel hitting the
bag it may have hit the bag but
i argue that the hand was on the back
when the heel hit i hope you're right
but i don't know if they're going to
have enough to overturn if they do what
we just did right there they should be
able to see that it's that he's safe
[Applause]
this is taking way too long
[Applause]
here we go watch the man to the left
all right
let's go first and third one man down
and the 3-1 pitch
fly ball center field birdie going back
toward the track
he's under it makes the catch tagging
from third is may todd and this ball
game is tied
the teams have traded sacrifice flies in
this game
andrew mccutchen
who does his job 18 runs batted in
[Applause]
we talked about the little things last
year in the winning record against the
philadelphia philly so far tonight the
marlins have done it
and jazz with the drive out to right
field turning looking gone two run over
100 miles an hour ends up in the right
field seats and the marlins take the
lead
[Applause]
jazz chisholm gets it done again 100
miles an hour at the top of the zone
against over alvarado i mean my goodness
yes you did jazz wow
and one
out toward right center field on the run
is birdie out toward the scoreboard and
it's off the scoreboard and birdie slams
into the wall
hoskins is coming home the throw to the
plate not in time
rbi double makes it a one-run game
flashbacks aaron rowan here
different part of the wall but
way to go down and get that change up
alec foam
takes carbs off the wall and and hit
some
neck
shoulder and then the neck
[Music]
has done so many things well
and this is rookie year
and he lines that one into right field
to base it oh double froze for a moment
one run will score rbi single we're tied
up at three
[Music]
good to see these guys battle back the
way they're doing
eleven hits now
the oh one to tourese
and he lines it into left field to base
hit one run is in rounding third his nap
he'll score
it's a two-run double for teres
and the phillies have taken the lead
it's five to three
i mean that's up in his eyes
[Music]
you know the team down eight nothing
yesterday tom i know they ended up
losing
10 to eight
but i think it has some residual effects
on this ball club today getting down
and getting down again
a high bouncer right side aguilar bare
hands and throws one of the play to run
scores
and the ball is pinballing around
6-3 phillies are on top
louie's rough six to three
and it's three and two to harper
and he lines it to right field that's in
for a base hit one is in here comes
mccutchen the throw to the plate by
chisholm not in time
two run single for harper
it's a seven run eighth inning
and the phillies lead it eight to three
three two breaking ball that does
absolutely nothing
smokes it to right field
[Music]
back at it again the one two
and a quarter strike three on the
outside corner with the splitter and the
phillies have come from behind to take
game one against the marlins by a final
score of eight to three
they stormed back
with a seven run eighth inning